do you think what drives a lot of career
criminals is the money or the juice
absolutely the Jews it's the juice in
the system and it's literally the last
thing use of the money I mean it it
money is always a factor I mean in
everything we do there's money well
because I've seen a thing with this this
guy he actually went to prison for like
20 years right had a felony and he was
found not guilty after 20 years they got
him out but he can't get a job yeah
because he has this he's in prison for
20 years so no one's hires him so lack
unemployment thing yeah so he has no
experience he gets back in the work
field and was like president 20 years
he's a huge black guy in his resume so
what's he know yeah drugs there's he
make this money really fast he knows
that what does he know what are you
gonna do that's the biggest problem if I
do think I also think that the the juice
is a bigger thing that a lot of people
realize I give you it gives you it gives
you an identity - right that's the thing
I was thinking about the other day as I
was driving my wife's Volvo with my
young child in the back in a car seat
going you know to drop her off it like a
virtual zoom for her you know
lock down class and I'm driving home and
I'm thinking to myself like I used as
much as I loved crack and meth and and
drinking I loved it but a big part of it
was like I felt like a legit bad boy
yeah there was the goosebumps I would
get when I would drive to North Pasadena
where I'm lips around it by [ __ ]
literal murderers and I'm gay and I'm
like this suburbanite little pretty boy
[ __ ] yeah my life would never go into
there where I got real [ __ ] heart pod
like I'm waiting and I'm like are the
cops coming and there's a [ __ ]
gangbanger about to drop me off crack
rocks and I think there was a there was
a [ __ ] excitement to it that I never
never never I was watching this
quarantine I was watching this cartel
show and these guys were in Venezuela
which is a [ __ ] show right but these
chicks make you look like the best you
should go there cheap anyways so these
two cartel members their mom was running
for a government spa
and if they haven't so that they were
being investigated by the feds and the
feds had undercover agents so they
played what they were saying and they go
yeah we need to flip this because we
need 20 million to fund our mom's
campaign we need 20 million like you get
your 20 million and it shows them and
then the the feds the undercover feds go
yeah so we're gonna do it in Hades
though or know what you do in Fiji we're
doing Fiji and they're right but I'm
gonna Fiji and like it's just better for
us there and they're like guy we're
gonna feed you well because they don't
have jurisdiction then it's Whaley the
game of Fiji they're gonna arrest if I
get him and it shows these two young men
good-looking their moms in government
they have money and it shows them on the
plane you know on their iPhones but like
what's up but for sure act like you've
been there before but I go what's up and
they're popping bottles a week my girl I
go what the [ __ ] are they doing like
they're fine and Joe and my girl goes
yeah but to them like that's like they
grew up in like that cartel world needs
something to them like yeah it's like an
honorable Jews them and I'm like I bet
it is fun like while you're doing it
yeah but it's a [ __ ] rush well that's
why compared to like I mean I know you
guys go I mean it could be the same as
like comparing like stand up like
fighting like the rush you got going
like walking yeah it's like the
endorphins the rush cuz a lot of people
get that from stand-up and I don't get
that from stand-up I like stand-up
because I think it's funny and you're
not gonna die doing so yeah I don't know
orphan like my job that you were doing I
just use a little work yeah yeah cuz
it's like almost like when I see like
like Special Forces guys and stuff like
talk about how like they're badass for
like killing people like there's no
ramifications for like you're killing
people like legally you know what I mean
like I'm like I know key people that
yeah you know it's like it's they like
I'm like there's a different thing when
you have that risk of you really on the
edge and everything can be taken away
there's just nothing there's nothing
like it well the special force you guys
have a risk of a guy that is that is a
huge part of the job talk to those guys
it's a huge part of the juice Jason and
you in they they've proven that in
high-stress situations you develop deep
bonds you secrete oxytocin yeah that's a
deep deep connection with the people
you're with so then now you got real
friends brothers blood right independent
hey you can depend
walk you've all been the fog why do you
want to be around a bunch of [ __ ]
people like actors when you come to
holidays and come give a [ __ ] about you
your show gets canceled they won't even
[ __ ] if you'd I'm [ __ ] one after
seven years you start you start these
guys in the business you [ __ ] give a
pound of your own flesh you go hungry
for these [ __ ] and when the
chips are down I'm [ __ ] I'm poor I
got a piss out of my huge dick you guys
keep calling no it's great and I go
throw up because I'm sick you see how
glove I'll trick you off Steve out I was
thinking about this too like I'll see El
Chapo had some sort of work ethic and
he's a smart dude yeah Lucky Luciano
who's basically started the business of
the Italian mafia I wonder if you took
those guys put them in regular business
settings like Apple or you know you know
company who whatever company Amazon I
wonder if they would succeed at the
regular business to not Joe I don't know
cause I don't you don't really have that
risk there it's like some it's you
business man they also like Todd they
make that [ __ ] sound so much more
complicated than it is the drug stuff
yeah like it's not I mean it is but it's
not like you know what to be like Elon
Musk you don't have to be like [ __ ]
if he's not gonna be the reason you know
that is it yeah like it's not like it's
more qualities and like its Lucky
Luciano his whole thing was we we don't
he didn't want to get into drugs his
yeah that's what's gonna get us in
trouble first like if we get into drugs
gonna crackdown us we shouldn't get into
drugs and the time I fit in the
beginning of drugs and that's one of the
reasons they got busted but his whole
thing was he what he did run a pretty
tight busy yeah like and what if you
take that a pride that that leaders and
people rectum I worked out you can't
kill people but yank that and put them
in a regular business setting would they
still succeed I would like like would
Pablo Escobar who's you know they say
worth like four billion dollars at his
height y'all see had some sort of
logistics business my guys didn't have
no topple think of me guys there are
that start at a low level and he built
his obviously killing people but built
his way up and then figured things out
right Wilfred
from X's and O's standpoint I think you
make a good point like obviously they're
capable but one wonders like if you
don't love what you're doing would you
be willing to commit to doing it meeting
like the same passion like I knew I knew
a lot of guys when I was in like the
punk rock hardcore world like I knew
these guys that were like especially in
like grindcore bands and death metal
bands where they knew going in they
weren't gonna get big listenership they
weren't gonna sell a lot of records they
weren't to make a lot of money shot Ian
but they were so [ __ ] technically
skilled at playing guitar they were so
worlds ahead of most people and and I go
like you're so good play Nick why don't
you go be daily role and they go I don't
want I don't like it I want to play that
music it doesn't excite me and I think
they can sit there and they can spend
1213 hours going over these obscure
scales because that's what pumps them up
but if you tell them you know you could
make a lot more money you can have a lot
more longevity being a studio musician
and they'd be like well [ __ ] you I don't
doesn't it doesn't get it going you know
so whenever there's like that seem that
similarity it's like same thing because
that way even if you went to Pablo
Escobar I can do instead of cocaine
let's have you push pharmaceutical drugs
right yeah it's legal but there's a big
market dude so let's put your brain
behind that and do that and what if you
just flourish yeah I just think about
all the logistical have to go through
now especially with the feds and you
know with the with the wall and you know
all those stuff because what drug cartel
members dude you maybe you know better
than me Stevie but they want the least
resistance the past path of least
resistance like water right yeah
wherever the water's gonna go where it
gets the least resistance so they're
doing submarines they're going from
Venezuela you know figured they had all
these little boats all the cut the tons
of boats that would get only so far that
after we gassed and keep going but we
took that away
so then what they do they got high-end
high-end jets like jets that
billionaires use cuz and weird land and
no one would assume that they was loaded
with drug because like why would this
building I'd be doing drugs but they
just played the part of building it mmm
they'd have someone rent these huge sure
jazz a room that way so the director
can't see coming up with stuff yeah
you're always working on it but you know
they've done Studies on criminals
psychological profiles on criminals and
they usually have the same psychological
makeup as a race car driver or someone
who can take risks hi Rizzoli and and
well or special forces getting guys who
know guys who tell guys they're all tiny
little guy yeah it's a personality type
though where you don't get nervous the
way most people do you have a tracker a
jerk you know they don fight science or
sports science they did they study like
high clutch players right guys who just
were amazing athletes when all the chips
were down their heart rate didn't really
go up they just stayed so calm so
there's a personality trait I feel like
goes with people that take huge risks
whether it's be on must has that or Jeff
Bezos has that may mean Steve Jobs yeah
I'm a big I'm a big I'm a big Elon fan
but I think what goes on with Elon
unknown Savior no no I'm not this is not
an in anyways space my big fan but I
think what goes on with him is that you
have a man with a almost preposterous
science fiction IQ that is also bactrim
yeah there's air I so is he on the
spectrum or we just all so stupid
he's a different free talk to regular
people as like talking to food visionary
he's a visionary so as he goes very big
as a visionary he's got he's got you
know the idea I think he makes a billion
dollars what what I'm saying is I and
I'm certainly not qualified to make that
kind of claim like he's on the spectrum
addition that but I do know that there
he's different than us in the sense that
um I used to after my divorce I I was I
had this hard time even like getting
back into the world I was like the only
thing I was going good for me was was
work so I just [ __ ] said I'm gonna
commit myself to radio I'm gonna my
whole life's gonna be radio I'm gonna
worry about shake something about and
then after like a year I had this female
friend like I'd never thought in a
million years I would develop a friend
that I wouldn't [ __ ] that was female
like it's the only point for me in my
mind like that's the only
hang on girls I'm still that was and she
graduated from UCLA early and went to
MIT studying this very exotic form of
physics and then she was you know really
really really really smart smarter
brainy I'm Becky but she also was very
attractive and one things just kind of
fell into place in one night we ended up
doing oh yeah
and I would so I was like we're gonna
make this work we're actually friends I
like her she gets along together was it
hot body doubles usuals real brainy girl
says no I don't want important questions
I don't want to get you into your brains
issue because I don't want it people
will know I'm science but she was a
collegiate swimmer so like rats
it was a really attractive athletic girl
but she also happen to be like 170 IQ
and the problem was is like I said I'm
gonna make this relationship no matter
where you're going to hang out we go and
we hang out one day we go like oh I like
first like kind of date day who were you
know every and I realize like she is
very frustrated talking to me yeah
compared to her yeah and I would even I
was even insecure because I'm like oh my
gosh she thinks I'm such a dummy and
she's looking at me going okay and then
she you know wasn't big you know when he
wants you know he longs on Jerry yeah
where there's that weird where he goes
white any because he's like she's
sitting there at toast on 3rd in the you
know in West LA doing the same [ __ ]
thing to me and I and we just drifted
apart enters because and so my point
being is that like I think when you when
your brain works in such a unique way
it's almost a gravid inability to kind
of relate to the brands that don't work
in a unique way you know this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
Oh